we're [ __ ] fancy it's not that you  can't it's that you're not willing to  give up dumb [ __ ] for a better life  you're not willing to go backwards  you're not willing to make yourself  dramatically happier to move out of your  home and downsize and go into a  different neighborhood you're not  willing to go backwards that to me is  fascinating the fact that things were  their home car watch clothes going out  is holding people back from a  substantially happier life is  fascinating to me and something that we  need to debate because at the end of the  day that one at-bat is all we've got and  so if I can absolutely push you one  tangible item I see some people have  pads and pens and I'm fascinated by that  go ready go to a [ __ ] F uck ing  retirement home spend time collect data  realize regret is the worst and do  something about it